on-screen relationships aren't always
the same off-screen in fact some actors
said no to a role just because of a
grudge so who has bad blood maybe dom
and hobbes keep watching to find out
from the x-men to the lord of the rings
ian mckellen has done it all in show
business his versatile filmography and
endless list of accolades offer a
dizzying array of reasons why he's
considered one of the greatest thespians
of our time mckellen doesn't ask for
roles the roles come to him
[Music]
yet there is one iconic part he declined
based purely on a comment made by a
fellow british actor as mckellen
recalled in a bbc hard talk interview
the late richard harris lumped mckellen
in the same category as kenneth branagh
and derek jacoby what is that category
you ask not a very nice one despite
those actors prominence harris referred
to them as technically brilliant but
passionless actors
ouch when harris passed away the harry
potter producers reached out to mckellen
to take over the role of professor
dumbledore however mckellen couldn't
quite forget harris's opinion of him
mckellen revealed when they called me up
and said would i be interested in being
in the harry potter films they didn't
say what part i worked out what they
were thinking and i couldn't i couldn't
take over the part from an actor who i'd
known didn't approve of me cheekily he
added that he still played the quote
real wizard referring to gandalf of the
lord of the rings ultimately michael
gambon ended up replacing harris as
dumbledore for the rest of the films
bill murray is a true original from the
fact that he refuses to have a manager
or agent field his scripts to his
overall detachment from the movie biz he
dances to the beat of his own drum
however murray's laid-back demeanor
hasn't stopped him from being labeled
the murrakane by dan aykroyd or feuding
with other talents that latter trait has
even resulted in a rift between murray
and a collaborator he used to call a
close friend harold ramis and murray
were practically joined at the hip for
most of the 70s and 80s they teamed up
on everything from caddyshack to
ghostbusters but during the filming of
groundhog day their relationship took a
turn for the worse the two men disagreed
about the tone of the film murray wanted
something more existential while ramus
was looking for pure comedy their
argument grew so heated they refused to
speak to each other and only
communicated through assistance
don't mess with me porkchop
unfortunately this disagreement caused a
rift that lasted for years efforts were
made to bridge the gap with variable
results remus extended an olive branch
by offering murray a role in 2005's the
ice harvest but he declined respect
remained between the two talents however
reymus praised murray's work in 2009 and
expressed gratitude for what they'd done
together fortunately the two old friends
reconciled in 2014 shortly before reymus
passed away
when one looks back at batman forever
it's almost impossible to believe the
production actually happened considering
all the beef on set joel schumacher told
entertainment weekly that he'd heard
horror stories about val but decided to
hire him anyway this sort of decision
had worked out for him in the past after
all but kilmer was different schumacher
said they had a physical pushing match
he was being irrational and ballistic
with the first a.d the cameraman the
costume people he was badly behaved he
was rude and inappropriate i was forced
to tell him that this would not be
tolerated for one more second then we
had two weeks where he did not speak to
me but it was bliss in kilmer's memoir
val kilmer i'm your huckleberry the
actor reveals he struggled to act
because of the confining and heavy bat
suit this he claims led to the tension
between him and schumacher as a result
he decided not to return for batman and
robin schumacher though sees things
differently as he told ew he sort of
quit we sort of fired him it probably
depends on who's telling the story
regardless one truth emerges george
clooney became the one bearing the
burden of the bat suit
when a film pulls off a character named
dirk diggler it deserves all the
accolades possible and a heaping helping
of shut up and take my money memes to
boot fortunately paul thomas anderson's
1997 classic boogie nights received all
that and more including a best
supporting actor nomination for burt
reynolds who portrayed jack horner
despite positive reception from both
critics and audiences reynolds wasn't a
fan of the film or the director
according to the guardian he admitted
that he'd never even watched the entire
movie he told gq that he didn't want to
work with anderson ever again adding
personality wise we didn't fit i think
mostly because he was young and full of
himself every shot we did it was like
the first time that shot had ever been
done i remember the first shot we did in
boogie nights where i drive the car to
grauman's theater after he said isn't
that amazing and i named five pictures
that had the same kind of shot it wasn't
original anderson tried to mend fences
by offering reynolds a role in his next
project magnolia but the storied actor
turned it down he told the guardian that
he hated anderson before adding i'd done
my picture with paul thomas anderson
that was enough for me
while sex in the city is all about the
unbreakable bond between four new york
women making it wasn't quite a stroll
through central park in particular stars
kim cattrall who played bold samantha
jones and sarah jessica parker who
played open-hearted carrie bradshaw had
some major differences for years there
were rumblings that the two actors
didn't get along but for just as long
they seemed to be able to put their
personal feelings aside for the sake of
the show and two subsequent movies in
2017 however tensions escalated to new
heights after catrell failed to sign on
for the proposed sex in the city three
not long after this her brother passed
away and parker reached out to offer her
condolences catrell didn't appreciate
this gesture she took to her instagram
account where she addressed parker
directly your continuous reaching out is
a painful reminder of how cruel you
really were then and now let me make
this very clear if i haven't already you
are not my family you are not my friend
so i'm writing to tell you one last time
to stop exploiting our tragedy in order
to restore your nice girl persona
unsurprisingly cattrell decided not to
join the 2021 hbo max sex and the city
revival series and just like that
imagine this for a second dwayne the
rock johnson and vin diesel having a
heated disagreement on set can't you
practically smell all the testosterone
in the air perhaps this didn't help
matters as johnson possibly blasted his
co-star in a now deleted 2016 post to
his instagram account he didn't name
names but his feelings were clear of his
male fast and furious co-stars he said
some conduct themselves as stand-up man
and true professionals while others
don't candia
while the actors were quick to downplay
the feud a 2021 vanity fair interview
with johnson revealed the full extent of
it turns out johnson only returned for
the fate of the furious under the strict
rule that he and diesel not share any
scenes together johnson said i wanted to
forego drama i thought that that was the
best thing to do for everybody since
then the two have taken subtle digs at
one another in a variety of ways leading
many to speculate that johnson's absence
from f9 was due to the continued
hostility between him and diesel there's
no irrefutable confirmation that this
was the case however and the stars have
gone out of their way to show each other
respect does that mean the feud is over
no one knows the future could hold
anything for these two in the franchise
they share especially if the rock
decides it's octane that he wants to be
cooking
the real reason behind charlie sheen's
exit from two and a half men is one of
the most complicated entertainment
stories of the 2010s in 2011 the show
went on a hiatus in an effort to help
the actor deal with his personal
problems however sheen refused to enter
a rehab facility and proceeded to start
a bizarre public fight with showrunner
chuck laurie eventually the actor was
fired from the sitcom he responded by
penning a letter that was published on
tmz he wrote i wish lori nothing but
pain in his silly travels especially if
they wind up in my octagon clearly i
have defeated this earthworm with my
words imagine what i would have done
with my fire breathing fists two and a
half men continued without sheen however
the producers offered him an opportunity
to return for the series finale as
laurie explained sheen declined because
he wanted the ending to spin off into
another sitcom called the harpers
according to yahoo in the years since
the incident sheen has admitted that he
could have handled the whole situation
better maybe the grudge between him and
lori is well and truly over now
the show might have been called charmed
but it probably should have been named
cursed judging by all the drama that
happened on set for shannon doherty and
alyssa milano their beef got so bad the
former decided she'd had enough and left
the show all together after season three
chatting about her decision to
entertainment tonight doherty said there
was too much drama on the set and not
enough passion for the work you know i'm
30 years old and i don't have time for
drama in my life anymore i want to work
with actors who really really care and
that want to be there every single day
yikes years later milano and dougherty
reconnected and repaired their
relationship speaking on e's daily pop
in 2017 milano said that they made
amends via twitter dms
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]